kalbitz bleibt das ist der wunsch seine
anhänger vergangenen freitag in berlin
doch das landgericht bestätigt afd
rechtsaußen andreas kalbitz darf nicht
mehr mitglied der afg sein
kalbitz soll verschwiegen haben dass er
mitglied der neonazi organisation
heimattreue deutsche jugend war und so
wurden aus parteifreunden feinde kalbitz
gegen motten
wir wollen eine klare brandmauer nach
rechts außen haben wir sind in unserer
rechtsposition bestätigt und ich würde
lügen wenn ich sagte dass ich mich
darüber nicht freuen
und noch eine freundschaft zerbrach die
zwischen leuten und seinem früheren
büroleiter früher verhalf als kara
leuten zu wahlkampf siegen heute lässt
er kaum eine gelegenheit aus beutels
autorität zu untergraben
das ist ein kleinkrieg den er hier
irgendwo angefangen habe aber er kann
das nicht als sieg verbuchen für sich
seit heute spielt machtspielchen da wäre
jede altpapier stolz drauf und das lässt
sich nicht verbergen und ich denke dass
er immer mehr an boden verliert es ist
nicht lange her da zeigte sich heute
gern mit ultrarechten kalbitz röcke und
co wollte deren unterstützung im märz
2020 erklärt der verfassungsschutz den
sogenannten flügel der afg als
rechtsextrem
[Applaus]
spätestens seitdem gibt sich leuten als
saubermann ersetzt die auflösung des afg
flügels rundum höcker und kalbitz durch
stefan brandner ist meistens
stellvertreter
doch er schießt ständig gegen seinen
chef auch in der sache kalbitz jürgen
heute betreibt das jetzt indirekt weiter
diese dieser versuch zu starten oder
sich von 1 einzelnen leuten zu trennen
ich persönlich halte das für falsch ich
habe andreas kalbitz immer also die zeit
wo ich ihn kenne das sind jetzt einige
jahre
ich habe nie zweifel an seiner
verfassungstreue oder was gehabt heute
muss die rache seiner partei feinde
fürchten denn er ist angreifbar
durch seine spendenaffäre plakate und
zeitungsanzeigen finanziert aus der
schweiz werden ihm zum verhängnis denn
die afd muss rund 270.000 euro strafe
zahlen für die illegale wahlkampfhilfe
stefan brandner schrieb im juli einen
antrag der es in sich hatte der
bundesvorstand solle prüfen ob der
bundes partei in der spenden sache
meuten regressansprüche gegen jörg
leuten oder andere zu stehen
im klartext top leuten die strafe selber
zahlen soll
270.000 euro plus anwaltskosten
erst dann weiß ich wie immer den begriff
der spendenaffäre zurück weil es keine
solche ist abgesehen davon ist aber
völlig legitim eventuelle
regressansprüche zu prüfen dann aber und
das haben wir herrn brandner auch sehr
deutlich gesagt nicht allein in einem
fall sondern in allen fällen waltons
gegner bringen jetzt diesen mann ins
spiel guido reil afd europaabgeordnete
auch er bekam illegale wahlkampfhilfe
aus der schweiz plakate auch dafür muss
die afg strafe zahlen 133000 euro
reil gibt sich reumütig auf seiner
internetseite
ich verspreche hier es wird keinerlei
finanzielle nachteile für die afg geben
durch die spendenaffäre jedoch auch in
der partei wurde aufgenommen dass es
eine klare spitze gegen oyten ist denn
es wurde ja im nachgang von jörg nolte
mindestens wasser erwerben
doch bisher ist vom parteivorsitzenden
leuten nicht bekannt dass er persönlich
haften will seine freunde im
fdp-bundesvorstand stehen ihm bei es
wird jörg leuten natürlich intensiv
angeschossen von interessierten kreisen
jetzt ganz besonders aus offenkundigen
naheliegenden interesse um kalbitz zu
schützen und deswegen leuten an zu
schießen
das wird an new york leuten ab reihen
davon bin ich überzeugt und so rückt fdp
fraktions chefin alice weiter in den
mittelpunkt des machtkampfes in der
partei denn auch sie ist verwickelt in
eine spendenaffäre
es geht um 132.000 euro aus der schweiz
vermutlich illegal in den vergangenen
tagen wurden dieser kontoauszüge
lanciert und journalisten zugespielt
geld für weidl aus der schweiz offiziell
von einer pharmafirma weitet büro
erklärt dazu gegenüber frontal 21
es ist offensichtlich dass mit alten
papieren etwas konstruiert werden soll
um frau dr weiter zu schaden
und so werden auch hieraus
parteifreunden feinde denn weidl trägt
meistens kurs nicht mit sich von kalbitz
zu trennen
doch dessen unterstützer fühlen sich
weiter stark und machen weiter
sie ignorieren den rauswurf laden
kalbitz zu veranstaltungen mit ihm ein
eine provokation für jörg deuten und
seine unterstützer dass ich das nicht
gut finden kann versteht sich von selbst
denn damit wird letztlich dem
bundesvorstand beschluss
zuwidergehandelt und dem
bundesschiedsgerichts lotte nicht mal
die graue eminenz der partei alexander
gauland kann die lager zusammenhalten
und so findet eine interne kritik des
abgeordneten uwe schulz ihren weg in die
öffentlichkeit er schreibt ich sehe
keine führung ich erkenne keinen roten
faden für unsere arbeit wenn sie in der
lage und willens wären den blick auf die
mitglieder und wähler zu richten
auf die reale situation draußen im lande
würden sich feststellen dass wir keine
alternativen bieten der wähler bemerkt
es schon die zerstrittenheit rechts ich
im sommer 2008 zehn kam die ard in
umfragen noch auf 16 prozent
inzwischen liegt sie nur noch bei 9
[Musik]
schließlich hat die afg keine antwort
auf die seit monaten wichtigste frage
wie umgehen mit der korona krise was wir
wissen geht von dem virus eine höhere
ansteckungsgefahr und ein größeres
mortalitätsrisiko aus als von der
gewöhnlichen grippe es ist keine
epidemie wie pest oder cholera sondern
ist eine verhältnismäßig leichte grippe
also es muss ein augenmerk zum beispiel
auf das konsequente tragen von mund- und
nasenschutz massen gelegt werden
der mundschutz wird in unserem land in
der gegenwart immer mehr zu einem symbol
für eine maulkorb demokratie höcker ruft
seine anhänger auf am wochenende in
berlin zu marschieren radikal gegen die
korona politik der bundesregierung
parteichef leuten muss zusehen wie seine
gegner ihre macht demonstrieren
ich gehe auch davon aus wenn man
wirklich von einem machtkampf reden
sollen wenn dieser machtkampf irgendwann
entschieden wird dann wird auch wir
haben heute das sieger aus dieser
geschichte sein
dem mitteldeutschen rundfunk gab hätte
heute ein interview
es war auch eine ansage gegen den
eigenen parteichef der geistes des
flügels das heißt auch gerade der geist
des solidarischen patriotismus wie hier
in thüringen auch gepflegt wird in der
afd
das ist etwas was weiterhin wichtig ist
für die partei und heute steht weiter zu
kalbitz hatte den ausschluss eines der
erfolgreichsten landes und
fraktionsvorsitz in unserer partei für
einen schweren fehler
auch wenn kalbitz vorerst weg ist
kämpfen seine mitstreiter weiter um die
macht in der ard
[Musik]